but in the meantime we do have the
winner of group a uh he has our quesada
Perez who won this game with the black
pieces so thank you for joining us and
uh let's go through the game so we saw
the end a little bit but uh let's start
from the beginning so we have seen this
position almost every round everyone
seems to be playing this fortnite's
English yeah it was uh there was a game
was a good
um the opening very strange because
I decide a play with a essays by B5 with
sacrifice upon
but I think I always was better were you
expecting this queen with remove a Queen
Bee Tree is
of course not it knows the the main of
the opening but is interesting
for program D5
um
I analyze this position uh two years ago
I think I I I see and before I was a
good idea but I don't know if
I am a V8
um okay A3 yes it that is a important
moment because if A4 a i play A5 no
um
Square before
and if default it wasn't interesting a
in ed
take take and D5
like before
um
so there's no way to defend yes I
it's for black
yeah E3
[Music]
ISO many times in this position because
I need to decide
if sacrifice Pawn or or play solid with
with E8 the disease but IEC B5 was a
good
idea so you spend some time so did you
decide this over the board or this is
something you had prepared yeah I I saw
this position two years ago but I don't
remember at all but I see
B5 is ideal
okay so you sacrifice upon he takes and
what is the idea behind the sacrifice
yes I I have more control for the center
[Music]
uh he so he played E4 and the idea is
this Knight doesn't cannot go here
before taking Okay so tactically you
just lose
so he has to go to remove
this are you sorry yes 24 33 is unsafe
fight I think it was a good move because
I prevailing and before
um
foreign
for whites
because my plan is my idea is D5 Bishop
disease and attack with King side
[Music]
um
yes I I saw the in the game and before I
I think this was for me it was a good
move
edacd Ed D5 we show A4 which this is
with a take
um
which we do taken between
yes yes but maybe I don't know F3
but it's trained for
was
best for black note and then you still
win the pond yeah yes the position
is
strength for him and if something like
H3 you probably just attack right yeah
the four is very strong yeah this is
very unpleasant so what did you think
what uh you saw that D4 is the best move
here I don't know but for me
I I think he played before but
he played Knight C2 was
what D5 uh before Queen C7 it was a a
good move because my Prime my idea 94
um so if he takes 94 left G3 and
ie5
take
three hours then you just Checkmate yeah
on the light squares that looks that
looks very dangerous
and so that's why he went Bishop B2 yes
if if H3
Queen E5
with idea quintify and Beverly Daniels
yeah because this King just has no
Defenders a problem at some point he has
to try something like a floor
yeah maybe
thanks thanks
this looks so dangerous it feels like
something is going between five with
the yeah this is problem right because
this is hanging this is everything is
hanging yeah everything is very
unpleasant
so he want Bishop B2 to stop this give
um
before are you sing a video E4 but later
I understand more the position and 94 is
I see was a good move because virtual
default
F3 take
take a
six
yeah
oh you want to take with the pawn yeah
97 for idea
research H4 a virtual f one and I don't
know I don't understand that position I
think is very complicated for ramp for
both for for that I play 1994.
so you played Knight G4 with the idea
that he has to take because otherwise G3
this is again 95 okay our first of
FC's
actually attack this so
B15 and don't take yes
okay so instead Bishop took you took and
now the whole idea is that this Knight
is just trapped here yeah as you did in
the game not like that and the snap just
doesn't have any squares to go to which
is kind of funny because it's not
something we see very often I have more
Contour I am better but will be
doof was uh uh we stay
no but it's hard to find moves right
yeah because what is your threat so you
want to trap the queen yeah
so I went Bishop B2 you played here
Bishop
c34 this is such a nice one because if
you take immediately then
Rook but at least a night
before with the struts forcing the
Knight T1
then YouTube yeah in this in that
position I think I well before I see
I think maybe
yes I just look where but
yeah so Bishop E3
or C3 but seriousness
for black but
it's not clear not clear
maybe one more
f55
just try to win immediately
so instead you decided to play okay
and then you took on before
[Music]
and then he managed to develop his
pieces but then he's just losing all his
funds unfortunately F3 a nine nine E5
with both ideas
[Music]
defending this guy so at which did you
hear that you already feel like you're
winning like it's over or still yeah
this position is winning for black and
on okay
success
[Music]
with TV
is winning for black yeah it was so
funny Europe went all the like to H4 h66
sometimes it wants to be suic all around
the port and then yeah your peace
domination is very strong here and
eventually yeah he just took everything
and the same tactic we saw in another
game with similar tactic with the idea
being you pick up this rook and you just
up an exchange yeah the problem with
with King yes
um well congratulations on your game and
who do you play tomorrow uh Christopher
Christopher you okay so Woody so we've
seen some of these games he's very well
prepared player so what do you expect
you will Face Tomorrow uh where
um I play with Christopher
uh
[Music]
in in Continental okay last round two
really yeah and we play with a
had a draw
um
yes but
I think this I feel good in this moments
I I lost to to round but I I happy with
my
my chest
[Music]
um
this tournament is very hard
I'll play a very strong but
tomorrow we'll play a nice game
it's a nice ways to finish is this your
last tournament in the US or do you have
any other tournaments no no yes are you
studying in Western yeah
okay yeah
and what I play many tournaments this
year here in United States yes
well good luck tomorrow thank you so
we're looking forward to an exciting
game you're very exciting opponent and
hopefully we can see you back here again
okay so that was yesterday Perez after
his win with the black pieces so he's
playing Crystal for you tomorrow